Film Courage: Robin, can you share with us
one of your toughest days here in Los Angeles?
Maybe an audition gone bad or whatever, and
then how you turned it around?
Robin Riker: Oh, yes!
I remember this very, very well.
I had just come off of my first television
series, it was the very first television series
ever on cable.
It was called BROTHERS.
It was on Showtime.
It ran for 5 years.
I had come off of that show and now I had
one year, so this day that you’re asking
about occurred, I had gone through one calendar
year of having deals made for 12 new shows,
okay.
So I went out on my auditions, it was me and
a couple of other people (you know), I signed
my contracts and everything was ready and
I didn’t get one of the shows.
Not one of them.
So this isn’t auditions that I didn’t
get.
These were deals that were made for me that
if I had walked out of the room with the job,
I would have had another television series.
And I went one calendar year, 12 of those
events and didn’t get one.
It was down to me and 2 other women and most
discouragingly, one of the episodes (one of
the pilots) was down to me and nobody else!
And I still didn’t get it because the producer/writer
decided that she wanted to play the role.
Now none of those shows ever went on to become
series but that didn’t mitigate my feelings
on this particular day and I was crushed.
I mean it was the hardest…I couldn’t believe
that this was what happened again in this
year.
And I literally went on my face on the rug
and just wept and wept and wept and then I
said [speaking to a higher power] “I just
want peace.
I want to be happy.
If you think that I’m supposed to move to
Kanas, raise chickens and have babies, I’ll
do it!
I just want a sign.
I have to know.
I have to know something.
I can’t take this any longer, this amount
of continual rejection after getting so close
to so many things.”
And I stopped crying because I really liked
the rug and I was getting schmutz on it so
I had to quit.
So right after I said the thing “I need
a sign!
I have to have something that is unequivocal.”…the
phone rang.
It was my agent.
I had an audition for a movie with the then
very old and very ailing Robert Mitchum, but
it was still Robert Mitchum!
And it was an old movie star and I’d watched
him when I was a little girl.
I was really excited about the audition.
And then I had this feeling…I will often
open a book with a metaphysical or spiritual
or just anything and just see what I see.
And I opened up…and it was something about
returning home a desert zephyr, returning
you home.
So I need a sign, the phone rings, I have
this audition, then I do the thing, I get
the reading about the zephyr, that feeling
to go home…I got this overwhelming desire
to return to Aspen, Colorado which is where
my parents owned their own legitimate theater
when I was a child.
So I said “I’m going to do it.”
And I made reservations and the name of the
train that went there was The Zephyr.
I went on the audition, I didn’t get it
but I had my sign.
You know it was…I said “If this is just
my vanity, let me know because I don’t want
to do this any longer.”
And if it’s not…I felt like this was what
I was supposed to do, all the signs when I
came here, I got work right away, I got my
SAG card right away, I got an agent right
away and then I didn’t work for awhile and
then I got jobs here and got jobs there and
waited cocktails at The Improv and The Comedy
store and all that in-between gigs.
And so I had gotten all of these signs so
I really believed and I grew up on stage and
this is what I love.
So I thought “Well?”
I’ve had all these other signs that things
were right.
That’s what I thought I was supposed to
be doing but you let me know if I’m not.
So when that call came I felt well that is
definitely a sign, you know?
And then I went away on the trip and I came
back home and on my deck outside my door was
a script for the TV show Murder She Wrote
and an offer to come and do it, no audition.
Just on the basis of the work of mine that
they’d seen before, they offered me the
job and I thought “Well, that’s my exclamation
point on the sign that I asked for.”
But that day, Karen.
That day…wheh!
That wrung me out.
Film Courage: And I think a lot of people
will have those on-the-rug-moments and I think
that they think it’s just them but isn’t
that part of the evolution of being in a town
where it’s competitive and you just have
to realize that it will come and then you’ll
get back up again.
Robin Riker: Right.
But the other thing that is critically important
to take away from this is if you get the feeling
that this isn’t for you, that you would
rather have a more stable sort of life, there
is no failure in that.
The failure is not trying.
The regret comes from not trying.
And believe me, if you come to Hollywood and
you live here for a few years and you get
a few jobs here and there and then you decide
it’s not what you want to do, you are still
going to have a lot more interesting stories
to tell around the old water cooler at your
job at Hewlett-Packard or wherever it is that
you end up working because you had an adventure
our here in Hollyweird, you know?
All the characters and strange things that
happen to you and the experiences and the
celebrities that you brush shoulders with
or actually broke bread with or knew.
You’ll have a great story and a great chapter
of your life.
So going back to another question you asked
about what aspects of the book [A Survivor's
Guide to Hollywood: How to Play the Game Without
Losing Your Soul by Robin Riker] people responded
to…having been given permission (as it were)
to change your mind is incredibly empowering.
It’s incredibly empowering.
You didn’t fail!
If you chose to go because you didn’t like
how you felt here, you win.
You came, you tried, you had some experiences
and you said “No!
Not for me, I’d rather do this…”
Because you have to make a lot of compromises
in this business.
There are a lot of family events that you
don’t get to go to even if it’s your child.
If you’ve been in the business a long time
and you know…you don’t get to go to all
of the little league games, you don’t get
to go to all of the family celebrations sometimes
because a job comes up.
The women in my family, who are some pretty
stupendous women, many of whom have passed
away in the last 5 or 6 years, they used to
go on a trip every spring to Rome or Greece
or to Paris or to somewhere and it was just
the ladies and they were a great bunch of
broads and that was a wonderful trip and I’d
buy a ticket every time and every time I would
have a pilot that I would have to…that they
made my contract for that I would either get
or not get and I had to cancel my trips, my
living my real life with my family and I didn’t
get them.
I didn’t get those pilots but you know that
hope of that big fish of going away in the
springtime (especially at that time) 10, 15
years ago,…the pilot season, fishing season.
You catch your big fish and you might be able
to live for years on the new show that you
just booked.
But I had to cancel two trips with some of
the most interesting, wonderful people for
the possibility of getting a job, neither
of which I landed.
So you sacrifice for this business.
So make sure that for the time that you are
sticking it out that you don’t sacrifice
your daily life, too.
Go to the beach, have a picnic, celebrate.